what's up everybody
Sean here with Sam and special guests
for this episode Brent Brent how do you
say your last name be sure be sure
alright cool
I've been trying to get you on for
months I think our email thread goes
back months the reason why is because
I'm interested in the business of buying
businesses I've been looking to do this
myself so after I sold my company I said
great I got some cash I can either put
this in the stock market I could do sure
you know I can go gamble this on a
riverboat or I can potentially buy a
cash flow and business that's a good
solid stable business and so I started
learning about that world stumbled
around and saw permanent equity and yeah
I've been interesting having you on on
the podcast since then so why don't you
tell us give us like you know the minute
version of who are you and then also
what is permanent equity yeah so permed
equity is we like schedules of family of
companies advise family-owned companies
so technically we're private equity firm
now we were just a small collection of
my own capital and beginning I was an
entrepreneur and I've been accidentally
bought a business about ten years ago
and that's what leaded to kind of what
we do today but raised a business yeah
so I had a mutual acquaintance saying
hey you should meet this guy he's in
your industry and he just got left at
the altar for the second time and I took
that to mean I should try to buy his
business because why else would you tell
me that he had no idea and he was just
trying to connect to people that were
you know in the same in the same field
or similar fields and so I don't know I
look about 2425 now I looked about 13 or
14 then and sat across from this guy and
told him I went to buy his business and
he laughed at me and said to two grown
men try to buy my business how in the
heck do you think you're gonna do it I
said I'll figure it out
we negotiated and he told me no thank
you
and in seven months later called me back
up and said all right let's move forward
and get it done so what was your company
before so I started a kind of collection
of regional marketing companies we
started in 2007 kind of really got going
in 2008
nine which were as you all know
interesting times but it actually
allowed us to grow and we adopted some
video technology and becoming standard
we think we were probably the first
people in the in the world to use it for
commercial purposes but what does this
mean what's regional marketing you know
we were doing look we were doing like ad
agency type of work we're doing media
buying we're doing digital work you know
trying to scrap and claw and and sort of
make a go of it yeah you for DISA Nate
you're you're an agency just figuring it
out yeah we Meijin see we had some
unusual talents kind of under that
agency because being in mid-missouri we
didn't have access to a lot of specialty
groups so we start building out our own
specialty groups so we built that
research we did some mobile and app
development as well and and then some
film work so those were kind of the
three unusual buckets that you typically
don't get animation see and how big give
us a sense of the like level of success
I think a lot of people one of the
things we hear a lot is from the
audience is like they hate when we fast
forward and someone's like yeah I did
this thing and then all of a sudden
these amazing opportunities opened up
and they sort of her like wait where
were they before and so give us the
before picture how are you doing how was
that business doing financial today was
it a big business small business yeah
yeah so we saw Lucy or so I'm trying to
spend a bit a while since I've thought
about the numbers so we grew to 26
employees I think at the peak of that
kind of before we were so we were doing
fine I can make a living doing it I'm
making good living doing it it wasn't
the agency business is hard it's really
really hard and I think that's probably
what I've learned in my career is I've
made all the mistakes I've tried and
tested a lot of business models and sort
of taste and try something you're like
up didn't realize how hard that was
gonna be and sort of you know move
around and so you know I would say you
know moderately successful regional
marketing firm nothing special I mean I
would say you know when yeah when we
bought the the firm that we did called
meaty cross you know we were kind of
co-equals is how I described you kind of
in the marketplace they were much more
focused on government contracts that we
were we didn't any government contracts
that was we really attracted about the
acquisition and the
able to combine those organizations gave
us a lot more cash flow than having them
set for just based on cross selling
different products that we had and being
able to fulfill a lot more of the a lot
more of the gross profit through sort of
a larger organization that they had been
farming out some stuff so that was uh it
was kind of a nice combination so did
you buy that first company under the
umbrella of your of your marketing
business yeah yeah correct
got it and so it wasn't its own entity
no well I mean it wasn't me technically
it was his own density but it was a
hundred percent owned by me and a
hundred percent the other firms owned by
me so I mean it's sure responsible so
you didn't have a girl found her or any
outside investors or anything yeah so I
bought it with an SBA loan thank God for
the SBA and so no it was it was just a
who's SBA loan and rolled the dice and
so just to give people a sense of where
you're at now
I think permanent equity you guys raised
a second fund 248 million
it's a 27-year fund which i think is
interesting and you can talk about that
and you have a ten year investment
period and so so the first fund 50
million second fund 250 million roughly
so what are you guys up to explain what
the model is here and why that should be
interesting for people yeah well so if
you think kind of from first principles
families got wealthy by getting involved
in a business and holding it for a very
long time and then over time using those
cash flows to either fund new
investments or opportunities and so we
just have very much this Amalur mindset
you know private equity is kind of the
main methodology of how people have
bought and sold companies that passed
and it's a very short time clock if you
think about it that way you're really
from the time you buy it on time you
sell it really needs to be probably no
more than four years or five years at
most and that's if you catch it kind of
early on in the lifecycle most private
equity funds are seven years with three
one-year extensions so up to ten years
maximum I mean technically you can't
sell the asset you can go longer than
that and everyone gets irritated at you
but you're expecting to sort of have the
capital return and so what that forces
is is you know you just can't think
longer than your time horizon for
holding the business and
when you combine that with a you know
most private equity firms are trying to
put in as little equity as they possibly
can and maximize the debt and so what
you end up doing is you take these great
family businesses have been around for a
long time you're sort of hitting them
with the needle and that trying to
supercharge them to grow them and get a
higher multiple when you sell and you're
making just very short-term decisions by
necessity and you're opening yourself up
which is pertinent now it wasn't as
pertinent three or four weeks ago but
now you're opening yourself up to a lot
of downside risk you just can't
withstand nearly as much shock as as you
could if you didn't have any debt so
we've just really taken the opposite
approach and said we want to own
businesses like a family would so we buy
with no intention of selling the
business and we're typically using no
debt as part of their transactions which
in the private equity world means that
we're the weirdest duck in the world so
how much what should total what's the
total revenue of the collection of
companies then we'll see so total
revenue gosh I mean and then I imagine
you guys try to run this like super
profitably so then if you have a hundred
and eighty million in revenue I bet you
have a forty million in cash flow oh
let's see here so hold on I you
literally put me on the spot here I have
not done our calculations recently yeah
I mean we're highly profitable I mean
the organization does real well I don't
know if we're at forty million because
we have some lower margin businesses
were lower than that but yeah we do real
well and and look I don't know all that
anymore right so just from a like I
don't want this to come across
differently than this
we've got investors the first fund owns
five of those investments and then I own
four outside the first fund that were
the the group that we put together
raised that first funded then the second
one we haven't deployed any of that
capital and yeah so we've got a bunch of
dry powder I mean obviously it's been
extremely fortuitous for us to raise the
time that we raised and I've been having
lots of conversations with our investors
and there should be should be lots of
opportunity lots of pain out there which
is unfortunate we've got to try to
tow that line we can talk about it
between being a white knight and a loan
shark and that's not an easy one to tow
right and so so let's just if we just
take a look at the the portfolio as is
what types of companies are you trying
to buy so you're trying to buy is it a
certain price point is it a certain
business model is it a certain type of
owner what are you trying to buy yeah so
we first want to buy something that we
thinks gonna be durable and around for a
really long time so you know if you look
at our current portfolio we are in the
swimming pool business like digging
holes in the ground shootin concrete we
also manufacturing in that space as well
another company that's unrelated in the
backyard product space it's a bunch of
confused and sell through mass retail we
are we military recruitment firm that
was the first firm that I acquired me t
cross we've got a military recruitment
firm so it's not like Legion for
military yeah so we actually work I mean
we have number of different clients but
one of our main clients is a civilian
branch of the Navy that resupplies the
ships that never came into port so it's
called Military Sealift Command and
we're responsible for finding and
onboarding all of their staff on a
yearly basis so it's like a staffing
firm for a ship yeah well for a whole
branch of military so it's there's their
staffing there's a lot fourteen fifteen
seventeen hundred civilian Mariners a
year into that division so it's a it's a
pretty large operation digital digital
yeah yeah we have you know online
application products but not mostly I
think there's a lot of physical
activities as well we have physic
Reuters it's not sexy where the rubber
meets the road real-deal business so we
were talking about some of the
differences you guys owned so me across
which is a military recruitment firm
swimming pool business back here at the
base so you have a couple of there so
you were saying you're looking for
durable businesses that's like we say
attribute one what are the other sort of
key attributes are you looking at yeah I
mean so we want to find a leadership
team that we can partner with there's so
many you know it's so hard to grow a
business right and so a lot of the
businesses were looking at we
we either called has been right before
the line of professionalization or maybe
has just crossed it and there's this
this real interesting you know sort of
in-between gap or a lot of these firms
they're they're too big to be small and
too small to be big and the leadership
teams kind of capped out they're just
brute forcing and as much as they
possibly can but they don't have the the
system's the talent on staff to be able
to grow larger and so a lot of the times
we're trying to figure out from them you
know do they want to get bigger there's
some there's some firms we talked to and
and they say well even though say I want
to get bigger but the you know the CEOs
answering 60 calls a day on a cell phone
and I mean there's just no way right and
so we're looking for a leadership team
that I think has the base skills it's
really really excellent at what they do
and we're looking for the company to
have a position in the marketplace that
is protected somehow right so I mean
we're not looking to get into just
commodity type businesses we want them
to have something unusual about them
that we can really build on and help
them grow and then you know this is
gonna sound like a like a maybe a
no-brainer obvious one but we gotta get
to a price in terms that that that are
acceptable to both parties right and
there's roughly 400 decisions that have
to be made to sort of dream that
acquisition process I mean that's 400
opportunities to not agree and and it's
very difficult and time-consuming and so
a lot of is just trying to make sure
that we think that a deal could be done
as well and and so when you say the
leadership team can you know what you
want them you want them to scale so why
are they selling if if you want them to
stay in place so they're not looking to
kind of like go do something else or
retire or whatever you you want them to
continue to operate and are they just
looking for liquidity what is the kind
of core motivation to sell and then do
you have a problem where once they've
sold or have you structure the deal so
that they're still incentivized to just
to stay on it do a good job yeah it's a
good question so part of it so the
leadership team in the the ownership is
not always the same thing
so some of the organizations that we get
involved in the owner is is very much
part-time and it hasn't been directly
involved in the business for a long time
and so for us it's actually that's a
that's a decently good situation because
we'd love to just you know continuity of
it keep the leadership team
well and and try to augment the talents
kind as we go along some of the owners
that we got involved in have stayed on
and and it's worked out great second
body the Apple they get down the road be
much larger than even their first
payment despite them selling a majority
of the company so it really is a
situation that's you know specific I
mean I would say yeah for the most part
some were wanting to take chips off the
table some you know realize that they
need help in scaling and growing so it's
you know it's a variety of different
reasons I would say that all of them
have an exit somehow in their minds I
mean if you're in your call it 30s or
40s and you want to work for the next
you know 30 40 years you know I don't
think many people like that are selling
their business at least in the size
range in the style of businesses that we
buy Hey earlier you said that one of the
best ways that families have created
wealth was by having a business and
owning it for a very long time so
something tells me that you study like
the wealth creation process I'm not
talking about like just building a
business that makes money but like like
creating like a true wealth and so I
guess what I'm wondering is with these
people who are building these companies
like I'm looking at I'm looking at like
things that maybe won't ever be like
massive massive but can create great
wealth so I'm looking at game group I'm
looking at selective search which is an
executive search nice personal
matchmaking that actually probably could
be big anyway when you're doing this
like what what are some of the paths I
mean like because in Silicon Valley
where Sean and I live the path for most
people or the SOL Silicon Valley stuff
which is sometimes [__] sometimes
not is creating something and raising
loads of money and only a very small
percentage and not truly getting wealthy
until after you sell it or not getting
liquidity at least and their salaries
will be a hundred two hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year so you can't
like and you're living in San Francisco
so you're not building it there but I
have a feeling that you guys look at
this differently is that true yeah well
I mean certainly the types of businesses
I mean you know we we have a rule we
don't buy from somebody who's not
already wealthy because if they didn't
get wealthy doing it we're not going to
so
they're already they're already doing
well I mean these people are the
chairman of the Country Club
they're there in the geographies they're
in they're probably the people that you
know the Chamber of Commerce would point
to and say they're a really vibrant good
local business or they're a bigger
business national business that's based
in that geography and so yeah I mean the
the they're getting wealthy from cash
flow yeah yeah these things make money I
mean you know the you know we're
typically I mean if we're getting
involved now the company is making more
than 3 million dollars a year of real
you know real owner earnings what it
sticks to the owner so look anybody and
these are closely held so typically the
owner will be one two maybe three or
four people at most and so you know
usually the one to three people that are
that are owning the company are doing
very well they've taken a lot of risk
which maybe sometimes it's hard for
people to see and they built it over a
long time but I mean yeah they've done
well for themselves and they're
successful in you know separately an
outside of the transaction itself and so
the the owner let's walk through a
typical one so i'm you know hypothetical
owner of a business that manufactures
wheelchairs we're based in Oklahoma and
I'm the owner I'm the sole owner and I
pull in let's call it three million
dollars a year
owner earnings yeah and owner earnings
would be different than sort of EBIT at
in this case rights here yeah I would
say even - uh operating interest any
sort of necessary capital expenditures
to keep the business on current
trajectory and a normalized compensation
structure for the owner if they're in
leadership of the company so it's like
kind of if you hired somebody to run the
company for you and you made all the
necessary investments how much would be
left over at your discretion where you
can either try to inject it back into
the company and grow it further or buy a
boat so fill in the blanks for me so if
I'm making 3 million a year what's a
typical a better than for that company
if the owners pulling in 3 million did
you look at yeah I mean probably even
odd would be three and a half to four
something like that they like say it
again so that was on three million in
owner earnings would be four million in
Nevada roughly yeah roughly I mean three
three and a half to four I mean depends
on the type of company we looked at an
aerospace company
couple years ago and they were doing 70
but done owner earnings was like three
and a half or four Y depends on because
it's because he doesn't so just they had
they just they needed a large cash
buffer no no they're having to reinvest
in equipment to just keep their market
share and sort of stay in place it just
you know all that cash flow would be
rolled back into buying new equipment
buying more inventory you know all the
all the type of things that the cash
sucked into and how are they getting the
money out of the business I mean are
they is it are they typically LLC's yeah
typically I mean it's a mixture I mean I
would say probably ninety ten maybe
eighty five fifteen is LLC's but either
way I mean if there are C Corp kills
typically C owners you know paying
themselves a lot to avoid that double
taxation so they're just paying
themselves big ol salaries and just
having to pay 50 percent tax yeah I mean
if you look in California if you live in
California so let's keep going for a
second so let's say you're at three
three and a half to four million eita
and when you guys go to buy these
businesses what type of multiple of
course it depends on industry and it's
very dependent but what's of range is it
1 X 2 X 3 X 4 X is that lit is that the
sweet spot of kind of the bulk of your
deals yeah I would say kind of three and
a half to five and a half would kind of
be the be a normal range I mean we maybe
would go higher for a really
high-quality asset but I would say
that's a pretty normal range in our
segment which is you know kind of our
strike zone is three to eight million
dollars of owner earnings so in that
range I mean on the upper end you can
get into more traditional private equity
territory and and you can see some so
well you used to see as a three weeks
ago this is again I got to read
orientate myself to the new reality but
yeah I would say three and a half to
five and a half times and then there's
usually a component of that that's held
back earned out or downside protected in
some way so we're typically paying to to
kind of two to three and a half times
cash and close and then the rest kind of
on on the upside depending on what
happens gotcha
so you might have a let's say ten
million dollar price tag for the cash at
close and then plus maybe four million
three million bucks that's that's earned
out so now you go to SBA and what you
were saying is that you guys don't do
debt you got years or no debt or you use
less debt than a part
a typical private equity firm yes so so
the SBA was on the first transaction I
did not you don't do sp my own money
that we have no we have no involvement
with banks or the SBA or anything like
that now I'm guys just do cash deals you
say here's ten million bucks we're done
now why don't you use debt yeah well so
that's one way to take a good company
make it a fragile company you know the
more debt you're layering on and the
sort of the wider the variation of
outcomes that you expect to happen and
obviously pandemic risk is something
that was not a lot of people's radars us
included until recently but it's a you
know it's a good example of why we think
that not levering these companies
especially in the beginning when you're
starting to get to know them I mean
until you own these companies you just
don't know what you're getting really
until you get you know underneath the
hood and there's always more risk there
than you think there will be right so
you know our our mentality has been
going with with all equity no debt try
to keep them very very robust on the
balance sheet and make sure and we're
buying these with full balance sheets
attached to them right so working
capital is all included so the net worth
of the company will be you know fairly
robust going into the transaction and
then force as we overtime as we build
cash into these companies then we can
decide what to do with it but working
capital bucket is kind of like them
you got to fill up the bucket first
right the owners can get anything out
right you got to keep the machinery
lubricated and when you buy a company
what is the first three months six
months are you hands-on with that is it
do you have an operating partner who
does that how do you guys make sure that
you and you buy an asset you know a
destabilize it and be you actually start
to grow it which is I assume why you
bought it in the first place yeah so so
our philosophy there's a lot of private
equity firms out there that have these
like you know 30-day 90 day 120 day
plans right we don't do that what we try
to do is is take a humble attitude
towards it and say look we we know some
things we have some talents but what we
want to learn and and and come alongside
them they're the experts they've been
doing it for a long time so there's a
team of 16 of us so so it's not
certainly if I don't get the impression
this is just me there's people far
talented more talented than I am on
staff and there we have a dual hook in
structure post close so our financial
team hooks into their fine
Angell team and creates feedback loops
and then we have a we calls portfolio
partner there kind of a Board of
Directors in a box that is overseeing
kind of the executive leadership helping
make very high-level decisions I mean
these are autonomous operating units I
mean so there's these are these are not
we're not injecting these people into
the companies to run them but they're in
touch with the leadership teams all the
time doing you know a variety different
types of calls and meetings throughout
the year and how many companies are
there there's nine that you guys own
yeah got it
that seems manageable yeah I mean it's
so for every kind of three to five
companies we we acquire we got a higher
one high-level financial person in one
portfolio partner and that's kind of
their their grouping of companies that
they're kind of running so we're almost
creating like a fractal if you want to
think about it that way down into the
organization so that it scales as
certain linearly in that way so Andrew
from tiny Charlie might have friends
with him and we I just shoot the [__]
with him every once in a while and he
emailed me he's like tweeted this thing
and he sent me the tweet of how he met a
guy who had a cool furniture store and
he goes oh this is neat you need to put
that on Shopify and okay I'll partner
with you let's do it now I own part of
it and he also did the same thing with
like a local news outlet in Victoria
where he just like seems like he's
spinning up stuff so fast I'm like
Andrew I don't know how you track all
this this is crazy they're not tracking
9 is easier then tracking the 9 is hard
but it's a little simpler because it
appears from the outside as though he
has got 40 different things how does how
does that compare do you think with
what's up in like tiny and this this is
keeping it on top of all this I mean and
that seems really hard to focus on where
to put your focus yeah I mean I I know
Andrew a little bit I don't know him
super well I mean it seems like he's
been successful I think they're getting
involved in in for the most part more
internet based software based type
companies so it's just a very different
model so I would say I have no idea how
they're organized internally I can tell
you four on our end is it a lot of work
is it difficult of course it is write
anything worthwhile is gonna be hard
you know internally how we've created
that structure though it's it creates a
very manageable focus group right so you
can you can allow a small group of
people be highly focused on on certain
outcomes as opposed to being all over
the place I mean I if it was just me and
a partner of mine like that we were
trying to ham and egg this thing like
I'd go nuts there's no way especially
right now I mean with all the turmoil
that's happening there's just no way you
can keep everything separate and you
know watch legislation that's coming out
and watch legal and accounting and meet
deadlines for audits and I mean it's it
takes a full team and so yeah I mean
we're obviously blessed to have that
earlier you talked about the one of the
things you buy a company I said that
there's the your sweet spot is in
between like it working out like it
working and it being professionalized
right yeah and I think that when I so I
start the company that I have I started
when I was 24 it's a good business now
but what I learned the hard way was that
actually to make something more valuable
you need to take yourself out of the
equation as opposed to like you know
this Mark Zuckerberg thing were you just
gonna super Superman this thing into
like existence it's actually far more
valuable even if that means you have a
lower revenue number to have it where
it's like a machine where people can be
where you put people in place and it's
not just on the shoulders of one person
sure can you and and I learned this from
David Houser shawnee no David Houser
I don't okay this guy named David Houser
he's one of our little we waste a little
bit of money he's one of our investors
he started grasshopper which it was like
yeah you know grasshopper okay okay so
it helps entrepreneurs it gives small
businesses a phone so it's like Google
Voice on steroids and he sold it per I
think 300 million dollar really
successful and he wasn't even the CEO he
started it and owned the company and
hired a CEO to run it and he taught me
how to do that and I think that's
fascinating can you talk abut but that's
different than one of our a lot of our
listeners probably think about they
think about if they're gonna start it
they gotta be like running the show can
you talk about where you've learned this
process and and why and I guess the
companies who you've bought how big
successfully navigated that to where the
owner is no longer like the person yeah
yeah so I mean for for us I'm equal one
I I knew my own limitations I knew that
there was no way that I could just brute
force this thing on my own and I mean I
think always subscribe to the bring
bring people that are far smarter and
more driven around you so that's how we
build the organization I I hope in three
to five years I'm completely useless and
they just give me my ball of yarn and
let me play with it so but in the
organizations that we look at we call
this found remote so this is probably
the biggest danger of acquisitions as
you buy a company that is that largely
all of the goodwill is tied up in the
relationships expertise drive of the
founder and there's no really way to
transition those separate from maybe
coming alongside them and over a very
long period of time making that
transition happen so I for us we try to
select against that we want to see
repeatable processes we see a healthy
layer of non-owner management we want to
be able to see that we always call it
you know hit by a bus risk so if anybody
in the organization can get my bus and
destroy the value of the business that's
just a no-go for us but tell me what
you've learned on these people so how do
I want to make my company like that
how have you what one of how they've
done it best yeah so I mean I think that
the methodology that we've seen work the
best is take the things that either you
aren't good at or you don't want to do
and start giving them to other people
and then over time as you sort of
continue to offload and offload and
offload you just kind of move up until
eventually there's nothing much for you
to really be working on I mean if you
have a lot of free time and you have a
lot of flexibility we always talk about
if you have the option ality to get
involved or not to get involved a lot of
these owners you being good example that
could probably add a lot of value if you
chose to get involved but you also know
that the things gonna work out fine if
you don't get involved and so that's
always ultimately the test now we also
have a lot of owners that we talk to and
they say oh I'm not needed in the office
at all I you know this thing runs itself
and we say to them oh that's great when
was the last time you to get vacation
they're like oh I think three years ago
I went on a weekend getaway with my wife
and yeah you know you're like really so
there's that balancing act of
self-awareness as well is there any
resources that you turn
- or have turned - to learn this or that
you can tell me and our audience to turn
to in order to learn how to do this
successfully gosh I don't it's more just
you know getting hit in the face over
and over again hard knocks Brett where
you finding these companies so are you
is it broker network are you are there
websites you use is it inbound because
you do a lot of content or you know what
is the explain how you find the
companies that you end up looking into
and potentially buying yeah yeah so
we're fortunate now we do a lot of
content out there actually podcast is
one of the things that it's been helpful
for us so thank you guys for having me
on but we it's all inbound at this point
so we're not going outbound to anybody
other way website oh there you go
I got your book if you're listening to
the audio version which you almost
certainly are I'm holding up the messy
marketplace which is Brinks book I
bought this like six months ago I bought
it right after we sold our business so
it wasn't really applicable I was kind
of like Oh what did I do wrong -
everything fine I think it turns out
just timing was good you know getting in
before the whole world descended into
chaos was it was a good idea a good time
to sell but I didn't know that you put
out this book and it seems like you do
more content than and I would say the
typical kind a buyer or private equity
firm yeah I mean I so so you know I own
most of my career to just ripping off
venture capital is in reality so you
just look at how did all the you know
Fred Wilson's Brad Feld Schuster's and
Greece and all those guys how did they
break into the world and it was
basically by pulling back the curtain
and helping educate people and so I mean
that's what we've we've taken that to
heart and we started very early on so
we've been producing boy cruising
content talking to people for probably
have seven or eight years now it's going
back a long time and so yeah over time
that compounds right in the beginning
you're just shouting into the darkness
and no one cares and then over time you
know you sort of get people's attention
our goal is just to be the first stop
for anybody who wants to sell their
business and we also try to be helpful
on the backend so all of its inbound we
have a scout network which is common in
Silicon Valley but very uncommon in in
private equity
so we've about 700 people now that that
Scout opportunities for us which is
fantastic
and we obviously pay them when we are
able to consummate the transaction any
of a capital camp right yeah yeah so
Patrick and I yeah so we we were
complaining one night about how all the
events and finance were terrible and how
it'd be fun to get like a cross-section
of people together specifically the you
know BC events private equity events
very few events to get sort of a broad
cross-section of people doing
interesting things together and so we
complained about it enough III said the
battery said well we just do something
about it and so he and I partnered up
and we hosted the first one last year is
fantastic about 250 people from 11
countries five continents came in and
that was great we have we did wonderful
time hosted in Columbia Missouri in my
backyard but it was you know I think
there was one other guy from Missouri
there so it was very not not a regional
crowd if you if you know what I'm saying
and unfortunately this year we had to
postpone it due to the virus so we're
pushing into September hopefully that we
were able to flatten enough by then that
we can we can have it hosting them give
us some predictions about the virus in
the the way the sort of what's happening
to businesses right now you know on one
hand you said your timing was was good
in the sense that you've raised your big
fund before all this and now a bunch of
businesses are gonna need liquidity
they're gonna need you know somebody
who's a stable capital partner to come
in and buy them what do you guys think
what's your prediction on how this gonna
play out well for you and for the
economy I would say yeah well so so for
let me believe broader I think what what
we're predicting and of course no one
has an idea right we're I'm trying to do
this we can't triangulate information we
think it's gonna be a pretty long if you
want to think about it a good analogy I
heard was a blizzard a winter or an ice
age right it's kind of about the three
stages probably you know I think the
blizzards gonna last for another at
least six to eight weeks probably longer
than that and then I think we're going
through a period of its to be hard to
restart a lot of these businesses so
there's in in theory it sounds oh
there's economic problems as nobody'll
you just kind of go into hibernation and
come back out
everything's fine right in practice
there's a lot of start/stop problems I
mean you guys have run businesses you
know if you had to mothball everything
and try to restart it I mean you're not
be able to do it it looks to be very
difficult to do it and so my guess is
there's me a lot of pain and suffering
so in our portfolio you know because we
don't use debt we have good balance
sheets and obviously we have a financial
firm to back it up
you know Ward me fine I mean a lot of
the businesses were involved in have
been doing better than we expected
probably two weeks ago with that said
you have no idea where demands gonna go
and I mean we're racing and we have
plans for you know depend on what level
of pain and suffering you know happens
well you know what the plan is and you
know we're gonna try to get the things
back up and running as fast as we
possibly can
you know the government intervention
that just came out is interesting and
how its structured so the Care Act just
got past 20-30 minutes ago and you know
it is it's better than nothing
it's going through the SBA and the SBA
is to be generous like the DMV of the
finance world and so it's not gonna be
an easy thing to get all that money
deployed also the the SBA lenders that
we're talking to that are at these banks
and we're not using the SBA but
obviously if it's forgivable loans then
be insane for us not to participate in
that and they don't even know what the
rules are right and so they're trying to
get triangulated on what things are so I
think there's gonna get a lot of
confusion I think it's gonna take a lot
of time to get the the money into
people's hands I'm not sure it's gonna
actually stem the tide as much as they
think it will on unemployment and so I
fear that unemployment could go to 2025
maybe even 30 percent which is you think
that's realistic yeah yeah fuckin'-a man
that's crazy
yeah the perspective but to put that in
perspective the great the the Great
Depression was what eight eighteen or
twenty I think it touched high 20s so so
I mean it's a peak and like I said I
mean I look I hope I'm wrong right let's
just say what it is I mean I hope that
that's on but this is not a good
environment for us actually I mean this
isn't interesting we could talk about as
being a you know a firm that has a lot
of cash right now
I don't think this is a good environment
for us at all I would much prefer a 2008
which is much more shallow downturn
recession this the violence of this is
basically rendering all information
available like a non-issue you just
can't there's nothing predictive about
what's happened in the past and what how
it goes in the future and demand curves
I mean we don't know no snow knows what
the demand curve looks what are you
betting for a 20% or 30% unemployment
rate well I'm not betting on it
that's why I think's gonna happen but I
think they do you think that's gonna
happen I think I think we'll probably
touch 20% I think we could touch 30%
yeah and I think we'll see it in the
next six weeks will be will be when it
really comes down my guess and I call
jobs the jobs number the unemployment
number that came out I had said
previously I thought it was gonna be
about 3.5 and it being about 3.3 which
was wildly higher than what the sort of
consensus was a million and it's look if
you're involved in small businesses and
you said there was million people that
finally found employment like I said
that's a good joke of course it was mean
way higher than that there's no it
couldn't be way higher than that I mean
what we're seeing is I mean I had a
buddy this week who laid off 4,000 5,000
employees this week had another friend
who laid off 585 of 600 I mean and this
just that's just me I mean what I know
they in the hotel industry or what was
it just worried that yeah food services
one and construction was the other so
it's just it's it's it's a tough I mean
why do you say this is this is not a
good time versus 2008 what what is the
core difference there yeah so the core
difference is the violence at which this
had has has downturned is basically you
could see in 2008 a nice trend right
line like you could see it's kind of
like a soft you know hidden private
businesses right I'm not gonna talk
about the stock market stock market in
private business which are totally
different
right but in in the stock market it was
you know sure he had a violence to it
and then you know kind of petered out
and another violence to it I mean this
happened it in [__] eight days right
right I mean obviously Lehman and all
that stuff compression know I'm talking
about right now
oh yeah right now that's why I'm saying
is right now in in private businesses
it is worse in private businesses than
its reflected in the stock market right
now it's hard to know what's priced in
and and what do you do with monetary
policy when you're basically an
unlimited bid I I don't know right but I
mean when you look at it from the
businesses that we interact with it's
carnage everywhere
I mean you maybe have I was saying 90%
of businesses have been adversely
affected 5% are probably you know sort
of unaffected and then maybe 5% have
some sort of tailwind that's weird
because of this but 90% are just it is
suffering I mean I is unbelievable
what's happening right now and I mean
Sean like for week only two weeks it
whenever you sent me that link Sean
there you go
the NBA's canceled yeah like a few hours
before that I booked a flight to Germany
and because I was go to a conference so
they paid for it but I like gave him my
information I was like yeah the
conference is on and then Sean sent me
this link on at seven or maybe five
o'clock at night and he goes the NBA is
cancelled I was like oh you mean like
they're just pausing it for like five
days it's like no no no like it's done
for the year
well whole content and then the next the
next day it was like oh my flights
cancelled
everyone's flights like it was like like
that was only two weeks ago Sean
yeah that's insane I remember people
thought I was crazy I started working
from home the week before everybody did
cuz I was like hey I think there's like
there's once on 100-year virus out there
I'm just gonna start working home we did
one podcast together and I was like yeah
I'm not doing any more in-person stuff
I'm not coming into the city I'm not
doing any of this and then it just felt
like day after day it's like escalation
escalation and now I think the the sort
of the data is outpacing the fear even
at this point I think that I think that
the situation is worse that people
realize even now because it's growing
exponentially and so so I totally hear
you Britney - my my sister own schools
my brother-in-law owns gyms my brother
owned a Christian films my brother owns
a concert promotion business nobody
prepares for zero revenue overnight for
two months you can't plan for that yeah
we were talking on our revenue I mean I
you know
again calculating my head may bring me a
160 this year let's say under normal I
think we may be 110 or 120 I mean we
have no idea I mean it depends on how
things go off the cliff right I mean
it's it's literally no one has any idea
what's gonna happen what we know is that
it's not good if you look across our
business I mean our military business is
very robust and obviously we want to
keep people you know employed in that
but if you look in construction there's
a longer lead time the the sales cycle
is longer right so you'll have a longer
tail to it but that's still if you're
shut down on its construction site we
were working one of our companies was
working on the Wynn casino they just
shut everything down I mean there's like
nothing new and so you have all the
materials you bought you have all the
labor that's right there you everything
you're coordinating it and what do you
do I mean it's like I said it was like
prohibition except for everything so
where's the opportunity here well I mean
the opportunity is there's gonna be a
lot of these family businesses that are
very durable you know business under any
sort of normal ish circumstances we
don't have easily gotten through 2008
which everyone would consider to be you
know a detonation prior to this that are
gonna need help and they're gonna need
capital to get through this they're
going to need capital to restart the
businesses if that's what it takes and
as well as just taking some chips off
the table I mean you know if you're
there's a lot of people we've talked to
that or they're holding on for sort of
last couple good years and then they
want to sell and you know we had these
conversations two or three months ago
with an owner who he's like look I'm in
my 70s I certainly can't go through
another 2008 but man business is really
good right now like I'm just gonna hold
on for another couple years I changed
you know it's tough and by the way I'm
not saying it was the right thing for
him to sell then even right I'm just
saying is like it's always a bet and you
know one of the things that is maybe
nice it's not you know if there's any
silver lining in this is I think people
had gotten certainly not immune but had
had gotten a pretty good resistance
built up to risk in general and I don't
think most people were seeing it I mean
I you know most of people were talking
to is a there's nothing on the horizon
there's no contagion that could cause
things to go down I mean I would hear
people say is all the time I mean what
could it be could it be student loan
debt maybe that's gonna be contained
could it be you know the bubble and
private equity oh that's gonna be
contained you know gosh we had no idea
what was getting ready to come down
right I think that's what Marc
Andreessen or maybe as Peter teal was
talking about once which is that when
everybody keeps asking you think X is a
bubble that's not the bubble right now
when we're all aware of it we're all
talking about it that's usually not the
actual bubble it's something that a very
few you know a small set of people are
sort of saying wait a minute we've
removed too many of the Jenga blocks
here this thing is about to tip and this
wasn't a bubble driven thing I mean I
you know as a war it literally is a work
like that I mean I think that's the best
analogy for I think where I think this
is closer to Pearl Harbor than it is to
2008 yeah oh I would I mean I would
absolutely agree and the issue is that
you know for Pearl Harbor obviously a
lot of people went over and fought but
it never come on to you know home soil I
think this is the thing is everyone's
fighting a war in their back door and I
don't think that's ever I mean look you
don't know you don't know what the death
rates are actually gonna turn out to be
you don't know what the infection rates
gonna be you know I certainly don't want
to be comparing it to things that are
horrible traumatic events that affect
generations and generations maybe and
god help us if it turns into that but at
the very least I mean the economic side
of it is just absolutely unprecedented
in every way right now and anybody who
thinks this is gonna be a short like V
recovery where it's gonna just pop right
back out of this thing it has never been
in a business and those are most the
people that I hear that are investors
saying stuff like that they've never
operated a business I mean you guys well
if this makes you feel any better Brett
I I feel horrible right now I called the
hospital to get I call I try to get a
test and they're like like don't waste
it on yourself but it sounds like you
have it and and so they think I have it
but it's not confirmed it sucks it
doesn't suck that bad
but for a 30-year old it stinks but it
doesn't stick I I describe it it just
yesterday cross the threshold the where
I would stay home from work and not
exercise really so you think you have it
yeah well me and the doctors but it's
not pretty pretty sure he has it I mean
like like breathing sucks but it's more
annoying than it is scary and yeah I am
so sorry man I had
no idea why no it's not look no my point
is not to get sympathy my point is to
let you know for most people it's not
the worst yeah
yeah that's that's great I mean look I I
hope that's the case I hope we can get
back to some semblance of normal life I
think that the unfortunately the
economic damage even if you wave the
magic wand and brought everyone back to
these businesses right away I I think
there's a lot of damage that's been done
depending on how long your lead cycles
are and all that stuff but I mean it's
just it's tough I mean it's tough as
demand dries up and you gotta think
about the supply chain all the way back
I mean people aren't ordering stuff from
factories right because their demands
dropping off on the other side it's the
fact if the store said no no we want you
know all of your inventory now they say
we don't need to sell you right right
because everyone's preparing for winter
and so yeah the stop start problems are
just gonna be tremendous wait Sean and
Brent you guys are both I mean we are I
have no idea where people are but we all
are people who probably aren't poor have
you guys cut your spending oh yeah for
sure I I did the first thing I did was I
cut the I cut my exposure to the stock
market which I think is gonna drop like
a rock now and so that was the first
that was the first thing I did because
that's more than spending is wealth
destruction and so I wanted to avoid
wealth destruction first but it's like
good your monthly subscriptions I didn't
I didn't go through that yet but we have
sort of like me and my wife now before
we do something we're like yeah do we
really need to and so we're you know
it's starting to creep in but we haven't
gone and audited and said hey necessary
unnecessary necessary unnecessary but
yeah you know probably should and
probably will even though like I have
plenty of money to last from a long very
long time I'm like I don't I'm gonna buy
the generic brand of this food we're
still spinning on food but we I mean if
you look at our bills in the past it's
been a lot of round travel and yeah
we're not doing that I mean we did we
did spring by the way the best
investment I've ever made I've got three
girls under six and we just bought a
bounce house and have in the backyard
and by the way that's the best it's the
best $300 I've ever spent my life
there's a business you should buy that
sounds not sexy but interesting enough
exactly bounce houses for
yeah okay my last question for Brent is
this your your 25 30 35 and currently
like let's just imagine you are I've no
idea how old you but let's say you're
young enough to like sorry okay well
let's say you're you're starting your
career you're in the middle early part
of your career now knowing what you know
about what makes valuable companies and
what builds wealth what are some
businesses that you'd want to start
right now and what would you optimize
for and what metrics would you try to
optimize for and how yeah I mean I think
it depends on what you're what you're
trying to optimize for if you're just
trying to I'm asking you well I'm asking
you for me personally I mean I I really
find value in balancing home life and
work right so family is super important
to me so my answers probably a little
bit different for me and I want to live
not a big city and so that's great I
want to hear what you would do yeah yeah
so if I was starting over today I would
probably start something in the
construction space or home services
space office services I want to get in
something that's it's I like competing
in areas where there's not a natural
selection of people into that right so
you don't wanna be in the winery
business because everyone in Silicon
Valley who exits a business goes and
buys a winery right and pumps a bunch of
money into it like I don't I don't want
to be in the the film business because
everybody who you know every son of a
billionaire you know makes movies you
know owning restaurants is really
difficult I mean separate from all the
stuff we're going through now because
everyone you know that makes me money
thinks is be easy and once they own
their own restaurant so I like two
things that sort of have a natural
selection biased against them like
nobody drives by somebody building a
swimming pool in Arizona in the summer
and says you know what I really want to
quit my job in the air conditioning and
go dig a hole in the ground right so we
want to get involved in things like that
I would try to take something probably
that that is small and partner with them
that they already have the
infrastructure in place the sort of the
the technical side and the systems there
and then I would really try to spend
some time you know how can we use you
latest technology to make us more
efficient try to build something that's
scalable sort of beyond a geography and
get a model down a billing model a sales
model down that we thought was
replicatable and that really had some
sort of moat around it and then I would
try to scale it over time and I yeah
anything specifically I think it would
depend on largely on what I could find
in the geography I mean here in Columbia
I mean there's there's a fantastic HVAC
service company that's still fairly
small but they've got great systems they
actually develop their own software be
something like that that I'd want to
partner with and say okay look look you
know I wanna get my hands dirty and get
involved in I mean I'm uh I'm not an
investor by heart like my I mean I'm an
entrepreneur that's what I love to do
and that's how we think about our
business is being operators and
entrepreneurs and so I I wouldn't
necessarily get involved in finance I
mean finance to me is a mechanism that
allows and enables entrepreneurship and
and you know running real companies it's
not trading paper back and forth so I
would probably get far more involved in
in sort of non tech entrepreneurship
which I know you guys are in Silicon
Valley and this can fall on deaf ears no
III like I like what you're saying but
you so you said HVAC you said each bag
was yeah pools lawn service I think I
service
yeah like lot like lawn and garden care
type stuff I mean have you ever tried to
get somebody call you back
it's yeah you want to hear something
cool we had a so Brian you know who
Brian's Scudamore is just got a more
1-800 GOT JUNK oh yeah yeah okay so the
guy own is the guy who owns a his name's
Brian he's Canadian he's friends with me
and Sean I shoot the [__] with him every
once in a while it's like a what is that
Sean like a 500 million dollar a year
company he owns all of it and he we
either me or show someone of us asked
him where opportunity is it he goes man
if I do the same thing I would do money
hunter got junk but I would do it from
lawn care or for irrigation yeah yeah
that's type stuff I'm talking about yeah
I mean there's there's all these like
strange
I mean niches that you can get into what
I would do is probably take my time and
go and talk to a lot of people who are
already in business and say what is your
biggest problem like who's the supplier
that you're most annoyed with you know
what's the customer that you have that's
just kill
that type of thing and I'd probably go
try to snake my way into one of those
one of those businesses and then just
it's really just about getting a
foothold right and that's what you need
is you need a foothold and then you can
start building on it from there
but yeah I mean that the problem is if
you've got a if you've got a boat that
you're trying to row that's rickety and
and it may look pretty on the outside
but it's just not gonna go anywhere it
doesn't matter how hard you row it and I
think that's a you know early my career
when I was involved in you know more the
agency business that's how I felt felt
like I mean I could just row that thing
as hard as I could I maybe get an inch
further and that's why I just want to
get out of businesses there like that
right all right well we should wrap it
up right thanks for coming man
if you're listening to this you want to
get a hold of you what's the best way
for people to follow you you know yeah
keep tabs become a scout whatever you
want yeah yeah so permanent equity calm
is that is the website and i'm on
twitter apperent be sure on LinkedIn I
mean just hit me wherever trying to be
very available and if I can be helpful
let us know yeah it's been wonderful to
have you guys on man and I hope you get
hope you feel better that doesn't sound
like any fun I mean I know you're
terrifying me so well no look I my point
was the opposite was to not terrified
look do I seem secure I mean I I am well
I'm sleeping in so I got it in get up
bed I didn't wake up until about 9:30 or
10:00 a.m. this morning because I I was
like I'm just gonna sleep as much as
possible I'm drinking a lot of water I I
would not exercise today that's how bad
I feel I would not go to work today but
I definitely would not even consider
going to a hospital I normally I
wouldn't even gone to a doctor oh all
right well though this is how I'm trying
to paint this as in a positive way as as
best as I can well Shawn don't don't you
get sick all right you can't get it
through zoom so we're good
all right guys hey take it easy really
appreciate it take care
[Music]